[Music]
i don't think there's ever been a video
game quite like spore
released in the late 2000s the game lets
you create and then guide a life form
from a microorganism in a tide pool to
an advanced creature in a galaxy
spanning civilization being able to
essentially design and play as your own
speculative creature really blew my mind
when i was younger i remember spending
hours trying to make my creations as
detailed as possible and coming up with
fake scientific attributes about how
they functioned in the ecosystems around
them of course you could also use sport
to create bizarre monstrosities and
throw the rulebook of biology out the
window after all the final game was
certainly not always a
scientifically accurate depiction of
evolution and often cartoonishly
over-exaggerated the stages of life i
also know a lot of content was cut
during its development which
disappointed some yet for all its
eccentricities spore remains an
evolution simulator that's quite
nostalgic to many myself included and
the game does explore a number of the
principles of evolution and biology
albeit in a simplified manner so for
this entry into the archive we'll make a
creature and play through the game
ourselves to gain an understanding of
how this virtual race for survival
relates to real scientific laws and as
an added challenge we'll try to keep our
creature within the parameters of
plausibility as much as such a thing is
possible in spore
so let's begin our multi-billion year
voyage through this simulated universe
the game opens on a swirling spiral
galaxy
the opening screen really sells the
potential of the journey you're about to
embark on from this distant perspective
anything seems possible we have a number
of gleaming planets upon which we can
begin our odyssey of adaptation this
particular world seems like a good fit
like earth it seems to have primarily
green plants to match the light
wavelengths of its host star it's worth
noting that in spore as in our own
universe alien planets might have
completely different colored foliage
depending on their star's wavelengths
we'll call this world planet curious and
kick off the simulation
the game begins with a sequence of an
asteroid hurtling past the planet's host
star and towards the planet itself
breaking through the atmosphere and
raining down into the sea the asteroid
carries with it hidden microorganisms
the concept of microorganisms surviving
in space for long periods might sound
like science fiction
but certain species of tardigrades or
water bears can indeed survive the
vacuum of outer space
so the idea that a similar microorganism
could hitch a ride to another planet on
an asteroid is a genuine scientific
theory and with the life form we'll be
guiding emerging from the rubble the
first stage of spore has officially
begun
while this section of the game is called
cell stage it seems to be a
multicellular organism from the very
beginning our species begins life on
this planet drifting through the tide
pool feeding on pieces of algae-like
plant matter on earth many tardigrades
live their lives in a similar manner
locating and feeding upon clumps of
wayward algae cells for sustenance as a
heterotrophic life form our
microorganism cannot produce food within
their body and must regularly consume
plant matter to continue functioning our
herbivore's mouth appears to be that of
a filter feeder and resembles that of
rotifers on earth
rotifers are among earth's most
successful microscopic filter feeders
vacuuming up plant matter using their
swirling mouth parts and if our
microorganism wants to get lunch they'll
have to be the first in a rapidly
expanding line for other emerging
herbivores are after the same resources
and when resources are limited
competition begins and so within this
tide pool the first race for survival on
planet curious is underway if our life
form is going to survive they need to
adapt
entering the cell editor we can see that
thus far we've been navigating the tide
pool using a single flagellum a long
whip-like structure that a wide range of
microorganisms used for locomotion some
microorganisms actually possess multiple
flagella to propel themselves along a
strategy we'll copy with our life form
our species also evolves a pair of
lateral spikes to fend off the
competition spikes are an extremely
basic adaptation found on the
microscopic level in life like the
heliozoa whose bodies are surrounded by
sharp projections that can spear other
microorganisms
now that our life form is looking rather
promising it's time we give this
particular iteration a name for now
we'll call them curiosis minimus over
the course of our multi-billion year
journey we'll see them change quite a
bit
back in the tide pool our extra flagella
have helped us out maneuver other
herbivores over the eons our species has
grown larger and can now feed on the
ends of bigger aquatic plant structures
again just like certain tardigrades
but it's no longer just herbivores
within this primordial battleground at
every turn newly emergent carnivores try
to snap at curiosis minimus these early
hunters resemble some of the oldest
predators in earth's fossil record from
the cambrian era nectocaris is a notable
example of an early carnivore and really
does look like a spore creature in most
reconstructions with all sorts of
unfriendly customers swarming the waters
the spikes of curiosis minimus are an
invaluable adaptation
over millions of years a new trait
arises in the form of navigational
appendages the game calls cilia on earth
the term cilia refers to hair-like
structures found on the surface of
various single-celled organisms in spore
cilia are clearly something different
analogous instead to the tiny primitive
fin structures present on certain
ichthyoplankton and with our new fins
the tide pool has never been easier to
navigate
so far we've subsisted entirely off
plants but in the interest of
documenting a wide variety of behaviors
i'm going to steer our life form down
the path of the omnivore in spore this
is possible through the development of a
proboscis or proboscis as it's sometimes
pronounced on earth various animal
species feed using a proboscis both
above the waves and in tidepool-like
environments as is the case for the
phylodoce lineata a species of worm that
uses its strange mouth to feed on
smaller organisms with our new mouth
would-be attackers are now a potential
source of nutrition over the next
several million years our species
flourishes developing a second pair of
fins for navigation and earning the new
name of curiosis aquaticus
we're now a far larger life form than
when we first began more comparable to a
small fish than a microorganism and
other life forms have followed suit with
life on planet curious becoming far more
sophisticated in general some organisms
can even deliver a sudden electric shock
if curiosis aquaticus gets too close
mastery over electricity is familiar in
our world with electric eels using disc
shaped cells packed into specialized
organs to generate their painful zaps
while this is a promising strategy
curiosis aquaticus is doing just fine
without it with our back fins becoming
larger and well defined the age of the
tide pool is about to come to an end
a cartoonish animation shows us that our
species has developed a brain
on earth the first brains emerge from
interconnected nerve nets simple nervous
systems that are still present in some
types of jellyfish with our developing
brain an enviable omnivore niche when it
comes to swimming in sludge curiosis
aquaticus rules the pool but a new stage
of life is about to begin on dry land
looking back at our history we've
already had quite the journey from
simple herbivore to complex omnivore and
now the next stage in our evolutionary
journey is evolving legs and crawling
out of the water the land to ocean
transition process was a complicated one
on earth and we don't see much of it in
spore although we can speculate as to
how it happens over millions of years
the fins of curiosis aquaticus likely
became larger and more muscular as
ecological conditions encouraged them to
spend more and more time at the water's
edge these early explorers likely
weren't the most graceful on land and
still live their lives very much tied to
the water like earth mud skippers but
eventually primitive legs emerged
and now with a fresh new color scheme
the rather strange life form will dub
curiosis irregularis is ready to leave
the water behind and take their first
steps as a proper land dweller as we
enter spore's creature stage a loading
screen informs us the kinds of creatures
we might encounter and as always it
looks to be quite an unusual bunch
curiosis irregularis starts off life on
land living in small communal nests and
generally lying low
on earth there are numerous types of
species that build their nests directly
on the ground but it's an exciting sign
of rising intelligence that our creature
has evolved to live in social units and
as a generalist omnivore curiosis
irregularis spends much of their time
foraging for food and scuttling along
unseen through the grasses
and they're not alone on land other
species perhaps distant relatives have
also made the land to water transition
during this early period the game gives
us the option to hunt them or try and
impress them socially using displays
like singing and dancing on earth all
manner of animals conduct similarly
unusual displays but typically only
within their own species to facilitate
courtship and mating but while this kind
of cross-species communication isn't
likely it's the system the game provides
us with so we'll have curiosis
irregularis show off their singing voice
to any creature who will listen
over the generations curiosis
irregularis will change quite a bit
within the creature editor spore gives
us the option to make pretty much any
changes we want like i said before you
can really push your creature to some
pretty absurd limits i remember spending
hours when i was younger just testing
the boundaries of what spore allowed you
to do while all that is fun it's not
quite how evolution works so we'll be
keeping the changes gradual on that note
one ancestral trait i've decided to
retain are the stock eyes eyes at the
end of stocks have their drawbacks but
they also have their advantages like a
better field of vision and frankly
they're just fun in nature stock eye
users include certain crabs and types of
snails so they're not an unheard of
characteristic in terms of a mouth this
leech-like suction mouth ringed with
primitive teeth seems like the most
likely to emerge from a proboscis
another useful adaptation spore offers
is a type of projectile venom i feel
like the closest analog to this in the
natural world is the chemical spray of
the spitting cobra so i've placed the
poison launcher in our creature's mouth
we can say it's derived from some kind
of salivary gland as that's where most
venom in nature emerges from
another shift that might feasibly occur
over millions of years is a change in
her creatures coloration colors and
patterns play a fascinating role across
earth's ecosystems
some have bright colors as a signal to
others of their kind or as a warning to
predators
others have colors that match their
environment to hide or to stalk prey
still others have colors and patterns
that mimic other forms of life to reduce
their chances of being targeted for our
purposes i've decided to stick with a
green pattern that matches our
environment in watching our creature in
motion i have to say that while i
endeavored to make a vaguely plausible
species they look a bit horrifying i'm
still quite attached to them though as
ages continue to pass our species grows
more and more adjusted to the land and
begins living in larger social groups
other species on planet curious are also
changing and diversifying some of whom
we impress with our social displays and
others who must be fended off we are
still an omnivore after all and with our
gnashing teeth and venomous spray we
represent a formidable threat yet we are
a food source for some larger more
specialized carnivores if our species is
really going to thrive we might have to
change our solitary hunting strategy
another age passes and we evolve a
larger mouth with more defined pseudo
teeth like many of the mouths and spore
this one does look a bit odd i do think
it's cool however that the abilities of
these mouths seem to be loosely inspired
by the behavior of real world animals
with the songbird like mouth better at
things like singing and the
crocodile-like mouth featuring one of
the strongest bites it's obviously an
oversimplification but it's a fun detail
nonetheless
sticking with our horrifying leech mouth
for now we can also upgrade our poison
spit and our talons and add a display
structure on our creatures shoulders
that will help us show off i imagine
this feather-like structure evolved from
some kind of rigid plate for the purpose
of attracting a mate and while that
might sound far-fetched some display
structures on earth which have evolved
to attract mates are far more elaborate
with a new pattern of stripes to help
our creature's legs blend into the tall
grasses i think it's time we gave this
iteration the new name of curiosis
striatus and this new chapter looks to
be an exciting one as our species social
intelligence has progressed to a point
where curiositis can hunt in a
coordinated pack with this critical
advantage our species is now frequently
able to out-compete lineages that were
once higher in the food web on occasion
the pack wanders into more trouble than
it can handle at one point a group of
curiosis striatus are crushed under the
foot of an epic a type of giant monster
that i remember being one of the scarier
parts of spore when i was younger at
another point we wander out to sea and
are swallowed by a creature from below
another part of the game i distinctly
remember finding terrifying but with
each new generation our pack hunting
omnivores are getting smarter and as the
pages of evolution continue to turn it's
possible that curiosis striatus might
become bipedal bipedalism is a form of
terrestrial locomotion where an organism
moves by means of its two rear limbs
while we associate this kind of walking
with humans all sorts of animals do it
for all sorts of reasons in dinosaurs
like the theropods for example
bipedalism is thought to have emerged to
free up their front limbs and allow them
to grasp fast-moving prey we can imagine
that primitive grasping digits might
emerge in our species for the same
reason with a new mouth and more complex
display structures this is a big shift
for our life form and as is sometimes
the case in spore while our design might
look pretty streamlined while standing
still in motion it looks a bit unusual
oh well with a new name to celebrate its
grasping digits curiosis digitatus is
born
and with our new hands fruit that was
once out of reach is now quite
accessible the social interactions of
curiosis digitatus are also more complex
moving in larger packs across the vast
open plains with our coordinated
movements in theropod-like anatomy we've
never been higher up on the food web
than we are now some curiosis digitatus
will even on occasion pick up sticks and
hold them in their hands while for the
moment this is just a product of
curiosity it's similar to the behavior
of early primates that gave rise to the
first hominids with these grasping
appendages encouraging their
inquisitiveness curiosis digitatus are
on the cusp of evolving higher
intelligence
curiosis digitatus now live in larger
nests they can impress just about any
species through their displays and hunt
just about any species with their fangs
claws and venomous spit and with another
cartoonish graphic conveying that our
brains have once again become larger in
size the final stage in our development
is upon us it's worth noting that while
in spore your creature evolves along a
direct path towards intelligence real
evolution is of course more meandering
with organisms adapting to physical
changes in their environment and not
necessarily
increasing in intelligence over time but
having a more streamlined journey
through evolution makes spore more
exciting speaking of which entering the
creature creator one last time we can
make the final upgrades these include a
four part mouth which is similar in some
ways to the mouth parts of certain
insects or fingers are also longer and
more dexterous with the critical
beginnings of an opposable thumb-like
digit and our display structures are
more extravagant than ever finally our
posture has become more upright this
remarkable iteration has earned the name
curiosis sapiens
looking onwards towards the future the
various social units of curiosis sapiens
will continue to thrive and achieve
greater complexity
these intelligent omnivores have come a
long way from their tiny filter-feeding
starting point
looking back through our history once
again it's been a long and winding road
to reach this point the stages after
cell and creature are all about
technological development so we won't be
covering them at least in this video
watching a creature evolving spore
remains a pretty special experience
despite the game's age i often see
people posting new stuff they've made
online
i know that spore almost had more
features and more realism in it and
while it's a shame that those elements
got cut the simulated galaxy we're left
with is still pretty unique i think part
of what keeps people coming back to this
game is that the experience is very much
what you make it you can push the
creature creator to its absolute limits
and make absurd monstrosities or you can
try to stay within the lines of
plausible biology it's up to you i'd
love to see another high-profile game
tackle something similar as i feel
there's real potential for a modern more
science-based take on this concept but
for now we can always fall back on the
weird and wonderful possibilities of
spore
as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support to help make videos like this
possible by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious
see you in the next video
you